well America has always been a country
of innovation and dynamism
entrepreneurship and I think that one of
the things that has made our country
great too is its heterogeneous
population where people come here from
all over the world and quite often the
people who do live their own nation with
and come to an unknown destination like
the United States are inherently
adventurous so we've had that
adventurous spirit that then has
embedded itself collectively in the
American consciousness I think all of
those factors combined have made it
possible for us to be in the forefront
of change social change as we had to
accommodate people from different
societies and different religions and so
forth and also changes that have taken
place in innovative science because
America has had the best university
system in the world for a long time and
so we have been innovators not only in
discoveries that's proven by Nobel
Prizes and chemistry and physics and
that sort of thing but we've been able
to put that into practical application
with new gadgets that people admire
we've had a serious problem in our
country in recent that's a few decades
in becoming more inclined toward
consumption and gratification oh how
much we own rather than have a spirit of
innovation and dynamism and producing
new products it was in the 1970s that
our nation first became a consumer
nation that is we bought from foreigners
more than we sold to foreigners and
increasingly that has been a blight on
our economic system increasingly every
year and now we have an enormous trade
deficit that is we buy from foreign
nations particularly China and others a
lot more than we sell them and it means
that they are producing the products
that we use and we used to be the main
producer of our goods to be sold to to
our competitive nations that were fairly
well-off and particularly to the
countries that were very poor that's
changed now so I think we've lost the
competitive edge that we had a number of
years ago
main subject of my thought was that was
oil and while I was in office we passed
some massive legislation that reverse
that trend we reduced oil imports from
eight and a half million tons per day
eight have been in barrels a day to a
less than half that in just five years
but now we've almost doubled what we had
to begin with so we're still heavily
dependent on other nations for not only
goods but also money now every time we
spend a dollar that we don't have we
have to borrow 40 cents of it for
instance from the Chinese to balance our
budget just by going deeper and deeper
in debt we've become increasingly
addicted to consumption of goods that we
don't produce ourselves and a lot of the
manufacturing has gone overseas and this
is so in the last few years it's been
not just handwork products like shirts
and and shoes in clothing but it's
become the advanced cutting-edge
technological products for instance when
I was in office we had the preeminent
position in the production of
alternative sources of energy windmills
and photovoltaic cells things of that
kind
now that ascendancy has moved to China
China's the number one producer of new
kinds of advanced photovoltaic cells for
instance and they're the number one
producers of advanced windmills to
utilize powerfulness Sun and directive
to the wind so we've lost that edge that
we used to have in scientific innovation
applications to to goods to be sold in
many ways that's also changing in the
electronic field almost all of the
materials that we use now of an advanced
tech technology I haven't and iPad and
also an iPod both of which are made in
China although we have designed them
here with Apple for instance so they're
manufactured overseas
well I think the entire population of
America has come tremendous strides
forward in dealing with the issue of
gays and I would say that the answer is
yes I don't know my next election but I
think in the near future because
step-by-step we have realized that this
issue of homosexuality has the same
adverse and progressive elements as we
as when we dealt with the race issue 50
years ago 40 years ago so I would say
that the country is getting acclimated
to a president who might be female who
might obviously now be black and who
might be as well a gay person yes I
would say the answer is yes
well I guess my biggest failure was not
getting reelected and I learned two
things one is that you ought not to have
let American hostages be held for 444
days in a foreign country without
extracting them I did the best I could
but I failed and I think another lesson
I learned is I should have paid more
attention to the organization of the
Democratic Party I was not only the
leader of our nation but I was also the
leader of the Democratic Party and I
think I failed in that respect to keep
the party United it was divided in my
relation campaign between me and the
people who were loyal to Senator Ted
Kennedy and then that cost me a lot of
votes so those were the two things that
I believe that could have been done
better
well I would say quickly that in the
midterm election I had I had great
success we wound up after the election
in 1978 with a majority of 19 in the
Senate and a majority of 119 in the
house so we had a very good success with
that but I think there what it's likely
to happen in the next two years I hope
is for President Obama to be much more
firm in letting his specific views be
known and then adhering to his
commitments through thick or thin I
think in this last two years he's been
faced with a totally irresponsible
Republican Party that have given him on
major issues sometimes zero votes in a
house in the house and in the US Senate
and I think he's tried maybe too much to
try to get a few of those Republican
votes which is now proved to be
impossible in the days when I was
president I had superb support from the
Republican Party in the House and Senate
and that gave me a chance to have a very
good success in my batting average with
the Congress so just stick to his guns
of be firm let the American people know
what what he wants quite without
equivocation and without doubt and don't
back down I'm sure those are the things
he's going to do in the next two years
well when I left office we had an
agreement a peace agreement between
Israel and Egypt not a word of which has
been violated and we have an agreement
from these buddies to withdraw from
their occupied territories in the West
Bank and also later the idea was for
them to withdraw from Syria and also
from Lebanon unfortunately in the last
25 years no progress has been made on
those issues that depend upon issues
with willingness to withdraw from
occupied territories and I don't think
peace is possible in this that comes of
course the other aspect of that is to
make sure that Israelis know that if
they do withdraw from the West Bank from
East Jerusalem from Syria and from
Lebanon that their security in their
integrity as a nation will be preserved
with a safety so that's been the
quandary in which we have wallowed in a
way for the last 25 years and my hope is
that we'll make some progress in the
near future
China changed in many ways because of a
decision I made to normalize diplomatic
relations between the United States and
China after 35 years of estrangement and
at the same time that China announced
that on December the 15th 1978 they also
announced that they would have a
complete reform within China and in
China's relationship with the outside
world and so since that date the 1st of
January in 1979
China has expanded its freedom within
its country and also has been very
aggressive in their foreign policy so
now no matter where you go in the world
or in any country in Africa or Latin
America in other places you'll find that
China is very deeply involved in the
affairs of that country so China I think
is now destined to be one of the great
powers not only in trade and commerce
they've now exceeded Japan in that
respect but also a great power in
international affairs and I don't
believe that China will ever in my
lifetime well maybe my children's
lifetime be equal to the United States
militarily speaking but they are very
careful to avoid any engagement in war
they are basically a peaceful country
which gives them another advantage over
the United States when we are much more
inclined to go to war for various
reasons so China is going to be a
competitor in the future I hope it'll be
a friendly relationship between the
United States and China
well I think a good husband for one
thing yes they depend on having a good
wife and I was lucky enough to choose
the right woman and we were married more
than 64 years ago
Rosa and I have learned a few things
first of all we give each other plenty
of space we don't try to encroach on the
private affairs off each other the Rosen
has our own major commitment so outside
the home and so do i we cooperate
whenever we can we share delightful
aspects of life like fly-fishing and
bird-watching and things of that kind
and also we've made the commitment then
large number of years ago not able to go
to sleep at night estranged if we do
have some arguments to in a day we have
almost a commitment before God that will
resolve that argument before we go to
sleep so I think those are the reasons
we've been able to enjoy each other's
company all this time